thanks again good so the agenda for the
rest of the afternoon is to talk about
algebraic lattices and learning with
errors over rings ring no bob ue and
I'll start by just reminding you what we
did last hour which is errors okay so we
have the dimension N and the modulus Q
and an error rate and solver is the
adversary has given these random noisy
products with a secret vector and the
goal is to either find the secret or to
distinguish the noisy products from the
uniform and we've seen that lwe is hard
it's got these quantum or classical
worst-case to average case reductions
and these then can be used to get
cryptography so that's the summary slide
from last time and lwe and also sis are
rather efficient well they're sort of
efficient so from the standards of much
cryptography historically they're quite
efficient for example if you want to get
one pseudo-random number so a scalar bi
modulo Q then well what does this cost
you right it costs you one inner product
so you have your secrets you have the
vector AI and then you just take the
inner product of these two and you add
some error to it and that gives you a
pseudo-random scalar so this bi looks
like it's random even though it's
basically the inner product of ANS okay
so that's pretty cheap right
pretty good for a pseudo-random
generator and in fact it's even better
than this we can amortize each of these
vectors AI over many different secrets
so there's a simple hybrid argument
showing that you can do that and you can
also amortize well it's already in the
definition of lwe for a single secret
you amortize over many different aces
more interestingly for each AI we can
have many different fixed secrets in
advance to get even more scalar
pseudo-random scalars out but still you
have to do quasi linear work per scalar
output a rather unfortunate though
disadvantage of lwe and s is is that the
crypto systems we use they have rather
large keys and ciphertext
okay so inherently in the system that I
showed you the crypto system from last
time you've got this public key which is
this like n by M matrix and in addition
the ciphertext is at least linear and
the dimension right so at least a linear
in n in its dimension so inherently
you've got a quadratic amount of time
required to encrypt and decrypt a
message you have to multiply this you
know matrix times some secret and do
quadratic work even to encrypt or
decrypt a single bit so that's a little
bit you know worse than than the story
I'm telling up top which is just cost
you an inner product so good so you know
quadratic is not terrible you know
compared to the modular exponentiation
or elliptic curve operations it's
actually rather cheap but in in practice
the N here can be quite large it has to
be in the many hundreds or even
thousands or more and so you know
quadratic is rather expensive or at
least for you know very high efficiency
needs so that's a that's something of a
disadvantage of
so this can kind of raise your thinking
like if you're not satisfied with the
efficiency that it has you maybe start
start thinking and imagining maybe we
could do better and here's one thing you
might hope for instead of to create a
pseudo random value instead of just
doing an interpretive doing an inner
product what if there was some other
kind of product operation that we could
do where we take a vector a and the
secret S and then we apply some kind of
other products which not doesn't give us
a scalar anymore gives us a vector what
if it gives us a vector say of the same
dimension and then we add some error
vector to that vector and we get now a
bi vector there so what if what that
would do you know and while we're
imagining is it would give us n
pseudo-random scalar values right this
whole vector like an n-dimensional
vector here we should hopefully be
pseudo-random using just one hopefully
cheap product operation between ans and
then plus the addition of there so like
that would be a dream right and so the
question is well if you want this how
could you define this product operation
so that it really is secure
so that the AI bi pairs are really
pseudo-random so that you can you know
use all the nice properties of decision
lwe constructions and you have to be
careful very careful with this it turns
out that you know in the usual case
where we talk about small error for
example coordinate wise multiplication
of vectors is completely insecure so you
can you can solve lwe very easily if if
this star operation is just the Hadamard
product coordinate wise up about
multiplication so I'll leave that as a
little exercise but it's it's quite
straightforward ok so that becomes
insecure so ok well that that product
operation doesn't work but maybe there's
something else that we could use perhaps
and in fact there is so the the kind of
the theme of
talk today will be describing exactly
what what kinds of products we can use
so that we do get some kind of
meaningful hardness security and so the
answer that we give is that the
multiplicate are the the star product
will be instead corresponding to
multiplication and like a polynomial
ring so for example consider the ring
zqx modulo some polynomial yes and yeah
okay so in fact this is a very fast
operation you can do this kind of
multiplication very efficiently using
for example fast Fourier transform you
can do it in n log n log n scalar
operations and that's essentially linear
time to do this product which gives you
so this is not our answer in fact this
this idea of using rings polynomial
rings or ring structures like these goes
all the way back to the entry crypto
system hoffstein Piper and Silverman
from 1998 and then was picked up and
used in Daniella's work introducing
these compact one-way functions based on
what's now known as ring sis and
so this this idea was used in n true
which is a doesn't have any kind of
provable or worst-case security
reductions behind it but then it has
been used also in sis type constructions
or sis type definitions but hadn't been
done for lwe until much later in both
over n square matrix multiplication
beats with the computational cost yes so
right so by the amortization trick you
can certainly turn these multiplications
into like matrix malls and then use fast
matrix multiplication for very big
dimensions matrix multiplication can be
faster and SM tonically you know it's
two point three whatever I think now
right
it still doesn't get you below the
quadratic barrier right so the the
amount of work required to do encryption
would still be inherently quadratic in
the dimension that would be more that'd
be matrix model so the whole hope or the
whole thing that I'm going to be talking
about it gets is getting us well below
quadratic the barrier you simply can't
go go below with standard l double
matrix multiplication
yeah but I mean just the size of the
thing is quadratic so you can't even
read can't even read the key and less
than yeah that's right so the amortized
maybe the amortized work would be
perhaps sublinear integrating here the
amortized what we'll do is something
with an amortized work of like constant
or until the software security parameter
yeah or the dimension yeah yeah so
you'll be doing at least quadratic work
in the security parameter and even
amortized it's going to be more than
constant or more than poly log and now
we'll do linear linear and yeah also oh
oh
see you could maybe make them kick in at
linear size messages if you use like n
by square root n or something like this
no n would be still the security
parameter because the secrets would be
dimension n right you have like a break
in the ecosystem which is to do the
engine is not to use in mattresses
brings the cost of breaking it to the
range whereas the point that's true
okay so what we're gonna do is is use
ideas like this using polynomial rings
and and so forth and fast operations in
them to get us you know by any by any
metric below the the quadratic barrier
but the focus will be on how to actually
define a secure L to be in the setting
and and actually prove something about
summary it used to be a relevant mean
but ok so I'll give two slides defining
lwe over rings one will be a very
simplified concrete a version and then
the other will be the general definition
which will introduce some some
subtleties so if you if you know
remember nothing else from the talk I
hope you you take away this definition
and then depending on how you know awake
you feel and how much number theory you
want to do so here's the oversimplified
version let's choose a ring this
following ring so this is the ring of
integer polynomials modulo X to the n
plus 1 and n will be a power of 2 here
what this means is you know every
element of this ring can be represented
as a polynomial degree less than n there
just by dividing by X to the n plus 1
and taking the remainder right and
concretely what that means is you
replace X to the N by negative 1 and you
replace X to the n plus 1 by negative X
and so everything kind of wraps around
folds over so that the degree stays
below it ok good and then then we'll
write our sub-q as the quotient of our
mod Q R so what that means is simply
that these coefficients now are modulo Q
integers okay so that's our ring well I
guess there's two rings here there's the
ordinary ring and then the ring
you okay so oh I just said it so
elements of arc you are simply
polynomials or can be seen as
polynomials of degree less than n with
modular coefficients and we can do very
fast multiplication in in this ring
using F of T okay
so as with regular lwe there are two
flavors of ring lwe there's a search
version and a decision version and they
look very similar to regular lwe but
here's how they're defined now so in
search we have a secret ring element s
as before and now this is a element of R
sub Q so again s is a polynomial of
bounded degree with mod Q coefficients
and now the attacker is given pairs
noisy random ring products now so not
noisy inner products but noisy ring
products so concretely we choose a
random a one from the ring mod Q and
then we give the attacker s times a plus
some error now what's a bit different or
important an important difference here
is that s times a is now a polynomial
right it's s times a we reduce mod X to
the n plus 1 so it's again a polynomial
we need to add an error polynomial so
what that means is there's some error to
be added in like each coefficient so you
imagine it looking something like this
it's kind of an n-dimensional error that
we draw from
and again as before we have some error
per error parameter alpha Q or some
width okay so we these are that's what a
random noisy ring product is and you can
give several such products to the
attacker and then the goal of the
attacker is to find the ring element
death now as before with plain lwe if
you didn't have the errors this problem
would be easy and is it so clear that
this problem is easy if you don't have
any error at it in good yeah so one
thing to do is just consider the
polynomial a and its matrix form so
multiplication by a a corresponds to a
matrix and then to solve for this well
you just have to multiply by the inverse
of that matrix one subtlety is that
inverse has to exist and it turns out
that with high likelihood this AI will
be invertible but if it isn't you can
get you can handle the there's some
linear dependencies you can throw out
the dependent vectors and maybe one more
sample you need to yes so with uh P
errors linear algebra is the answer but
really it's just division by by a
okay but it's what the air is the is
what makes this hard again as okay and
then decision is the same kind of the
same story you're given a bunch of pairs
which are either generated in this way
or are just uniformly random pairs and
you just have to decide which which it
is with some good advantage any question
so far about this concrete definition
one here another should I see where they
at this point that we have savings it
just seems like you returned the matrix
product in a different form so it's
unclear why yeah so where's the savings
here right so as was already mentioned
an element here of the ring kind of
stands in for a square matrix right so
multiplying by a can be seen as a linear
transformation and so it's standing in
for an N by n matrix but this is much
more compact right this is only n
coefficients and it's basically standing
in for n lwe samples this one n
dimensional vector or polynomial is now
replacing an N by n matrix with n and n
separate lwe samples so we're getting a
factor of n savings and in the space
we're also getting a factor of n savings
in the multiplication because we can do
this multiplication in quasi linear time
as opposed to a square matrix times a
vector and why are you then why don't
have like a 1 a 2 correspond to like the
coordinates as before
oh right good
so this is this a one is a full I mean
it's a full polynomial and then a two is
a uniformly independent random
polynomial a one is the life like the
here something and yeah so depending on
which what crypto system you're talking
about there may only be a single a one
or there might be a few a few of them
but certainly generally speaking we only
have a small number of such the way it's
presented here you need you need at
least two samples are accept two samples
to make it uniquely defined okay
question oh yeah so oh I'll go to that
to the next slide which is the general
yeah so right now I've picked a very
particular polynomial here the reason
why is this is what is known as the
cyclotomic polynomial and it's known as
the two nth cyclotomic polynomial so the
roots of this polynomial are the two end
primitive roots of unity which is a
number of nice properties for example
this is irreducible and all its roots
are roots of unity and and so we'll see
many advantages of that so reducible
polynomials are a can be a problem you
can define whatever you want but the
question we are focused on is what is
secure right yeah
sorry maybe it's a silly question but
would it be because the distribution of
s is uniform while the distribution of
the good okay so good so the question is
if there's no errors and looking at the
decision problem how do you know if
you've if you've guessed correctly how
do you know if you I may imagine that
you have two samples or three samples
you can divide this one by that you get
a candidate s and then you check whether
that's consistent with the second sample
if they're consistent you know that your
in this case if they're inconsistent
your in this case so you basically have
a perfect perfect distinguish other
questions about this set up here okay so
now let's see more generally how to
define this and there's some very
interesting things that come up so the
way we've defined it after a lot of
different basically playing with a lot
of different options is that we focus on
the case where the ring is what's known
as the ring of integers of a number
field K you know what that is great if
you don't know what that is
it's enough to say that often times such
a ring is ZX modulo some f of X which is
irreducible irreducible of an integers
so let's just focus on this case for
today this is this is already a rich
enough so we have the polynomials
integer polynomials modulo some
irreducible polynomial of degree N and
so that will be our ring and a very
important object is that this ring has
what's known as a dual ideal or it's
actually a fractional ideal but there's
a there's an ideal which we'll call our
dual or RV and this is a dual ideal with
respect to a certain geometry which will
define shortly
so this is this is an important object
which goes into the definition of the
problem but for now just imagine that
there's this ideal our RV which is
essentially an ideal so again we have an
integer modulus and RQ is the same it's
our mod Q R so now all the coefficients
are mod Q and then our V mod Q is is a
analogously RV and again we have a
Gaussian error and this is how the
problem is defined so again with search
we have a secret element this element s
actually belongs to the dual ideal mod Q
so you pick a pick an element from the
dual ideal and then you get or you give
independent samples aí and aí times S
Plus error one thing to notice is that
when you you sample this AI from the
ring and when you multiply a times s
well because this is an ideal the
product lives in our V everything's mod
Q so this is this product here lives in
our V mud Q and you add some arrow to so
here's a kind of a picture of an
alternative scenario where this this is
the shape of our V so our V as itself
can be seen as a lattice there's a way
we'll see how to do that and so when you
see it as a lattice it may not be a nice
you know rectangular or square lattice
it may look people with hexagonal or
something like that and so this is what
the picture would look like but
basically your products a times s you
know live you end up in a lattice point
here and then you add some error to it
to kind of
yeah yes and yes so it turns out they
they benefit both for the security
proofs for the efficiency of the crypto
systems and I want to say a third reason
but those are the only two just for the
general elegance of so yeah it kind of
all comes together in a win-win-win type
of situation when when defined in this
way well we can get the the worst case
to average case reductions will be will
be better this way they'll be tighter in
terms of the approximation factor that
you get I should I should convince you
offline of that
okay and then decision is the same way
Oh Oh is there another question yeah
great question okay so in the previous
case where f is X to the n plus 1 and a
power of 2 the dual ideal I can tell you
is actually equal to R but divide and in
the denominator so it's just a scale
that down a par it's it's 1 over N times
R so good actually it's a great question
which is why the simplified definition I
gave did not need the the dual ideal
because our v and r are the same it is a
z adjoined the root of unity yeah so the
dual ideal is just a just a shrinking
scaling down of the par and back up if
you wish there's no
okay so yeah so this is the the general
definition other questions about these
are great questions
okay so with this definition now we can
state some some hardness theorems
there's kind of two - hardness theorems
that will focus on this so there's the
initial ones that we proved in 2010 in
this paper and then and then there's a
subsequent one which addresses some gaps
in the first one so the nature of the
additional reductions are the follows we
have a worst-case - average case
reduction from approximate shortest
vector problem on arbitrary ideal
lattices of the ring I'll tell you what
idea lattices are and what the reduction
says is you know if you have an
algorithm for solving search ring lwe
then you get an algorithm for
approximating SBP in arbitrary ideal
lattices of the brain and as as notice
before this is just as before this is a
quantum algorithm this reduction works
though for any ring of integers in any
so completely general with regard to the
choice of ring so that gets you from
worst case problems to search ring lwe
and then analogously to with the regular
lwe scenario we have a search - decision
reduction it turns out this is much much
trickier to do than in the plain lwe
setting and it's basically because
decision asks that like all n you know
the entire be polynomial be
pseudo-random there's a lot of
pseudo-random scalars that you need in
there and they should look like a
completely random
cooter so that requires a lot more work
and in particular we were only able to
get this for the cyclotomic rings so but
it was classical so this link here is
classical but it's for a restricted much
very restricted special class events so
that's aquatic inequities with
no this wasn't even defined you don't
know that I mean well so this is for any
ring sure
independent yeah
okay so then there's a new reduction
which says well it gets rid of this in
the middle so the problem is going from
here to here
oh restricted to classical or cyclotomic
rings and that was unfortunate we didn't
want to be so restricted so we said well
what if we could just go from here to
here directly and in fact that's that's
what it does so the same thing on the
left here as a peer this is quantum
works for any ring and it just goes
directly to a decision so if you want
hardness of decision you don't need to
limit yourself to and then well as usual
if you assume decision hard you can
build a lot of criticisms in fact mmm
almost well I'll say most crypto systems
from lwe pretty straightforwardly pour
it over to ring all w/e you open up to
check you know does all the do all the
things in the proof work out sometimes
they do sometimes they don't but often
they the other way around always they
think yeah this is bringing all the B's
a special case
it could port from ring lwe to owner I
see I see what you mean it's Rob this
why you would want to do it if all you
care about is efficiency you're actually
making it worse but if you care about
assumptions then now yeah I see where do
you want to take a ring off with it okay
so let me say a little bit more about
this geometry so when we have a ring
that looks like this the the goal is to
to give it a geometry and to get a get
lattices from this so for example when
you have Z X mod f of X and f is
irreducible then this F has n different
roots call them alpha and so there are
what's known is that there's exactly n
different ring embeddings or injective
homomorphisms
from this ring into the complex numbers
and these homomorphisms are just given
by evaluating the polynomial at a
particular root of that so if you if you
take this polynomial and just evaluate
it at alpha I then that gives you a
complex number and this is a ring
homomorphism so moulting you know two
polynomials of course the results are
added multiplying two polynomials the
results are also added this is because
you can add or subtract or multiply add
or subtract multiples of F and those the
result is it vanishes right developers
sir so good so we have these n
embeddings ring embeddings and so what's
known as the canonical embedding or
makovski embedding of the ring into the
n dimensional complex numbers is to just
apply all of these and embeddings in
some fixed sequence so just Sigma V is
just applying a to all of the n brutes
and this is a very useful way of getting
a geometry this goes all the way back to
the 1800s I think in algebraic number
theory where we can basically define
geometric quantities on the ring via
this canonical embedding right so when I
talk about like the Euclidean norm of a
I really mean the Euclidean norm of its
embedding into C to the M and we can
also get we can also get lattices so in
particular the ring R and that there's a
lattice in fact any ideal a here or here
so these are a these a and B are
elements of the ring yeah so this a this
Sigma here this canonical embedding is
is very nice it's got a lot of nice
properties both addition and
multiplication map to coordinate wise
addition to multiplication
and that's just because each of these is
a ring okay so if you the the embedding
of the product is just the coordinate
waste product same for some okay so one
useful consequence of this is that it
gives us what's known as an expansion
bound it tells you how big can the
product of two ring elements be relative
to the original two elements so in
particular if you want to know the
Euclidean norm of a times B well that's
at most the infinity norm a max norm of
a time's the Euclidean norm of B or
switch the roles it's a community so
this alpha sorry a sub infinity can be
seen as like the expansion of a under
multiplication
so we can get bounds like this they
actually apply more generally this
applies to any p-norm not just the the
to normal so you can understand
multiplication and addition very nicely
through this embedding and this
expansion is element specific right it's
a it's not a global global property or
anything so let me do two examples okay
they're both pretty simple examples but
they show a little bit of the variety
that you can encounter here so in one
example let's use a power of two
cyclotomic which is what I started with
originally but I can only use the x
squared here I can't go in a higher
dimension so the fourth cyclotomic is
this and the embeddings just map x2 plus
or minus square minus 1 so when you do
the embedding well it's enough to see
let's just embed the element 1 and the
element ax and so here you get 1 comma 1
and here you get plus I and minus I so I
guess I'm well I would normally need 4
dimensions but it lies in a two
dimensional subspace so it looks
basically like this
by the right subspace so this is the
lattice right the ring here embeds as
this lattice which is just a rotated
square good and more generally in power
of two cyclotomic which was the key case
of interest from before we have the
following nice things every power of X
as Euclidean norm n because it has
infinity no arm equal to 1 so all these
powers of X when you apply the embedding
they all become roots of unity vector
which is all all the centuries of rich
community so you get this ok and in fact
more generally the the picture is very
similar to what we see here this power
basis the power is 1x all the way up to
X to the N minus 1 embeds as an
orthogonal basis so these vectors are
pairwise orthogonal and they all have
length square root n so really this is
just a square lattice that's kind of
it's a rotation and a scaling of the
integer lattice essentially the integer
lattice with no so any question about
this this is for a power of two cycle
tonics we can look at a one more example
which is slightly more interesting the
third cyclotomic looks like this so this
is now the polynomial modulus and the
roots of it are it's the negative 1 plus
or minus square root negative 3 over 2
so now the lattice embeds to something
like this one embeds is 1 comma 1 but X
embeds as this thing and the angle
between these is 120 degrees so you get
this hexagonal lattice instead and but
still many of the event and many of the
nice properties that we saw for power to
cyclotomic still hold here so again all
these powers of X when you embed them
they have Euclidean norm one and they
have expansion sorry
Euclidean norm root n
an expansion equal to one this is for
the power basis is now not orthogonal in
the non power of two case but maybe
that's okay we have a way of dealing
with it so one consequence of this is
that elements which are short might have
large coefficients relative to this
basis so for example if you look at this
vector here it's just as short as these
vectors the same length but its
coefficient vector is 1 comma 1 so
there's some distortion between like the
polynomial written as a vector of
coefficients and the actual length or
shape of that so any question about
these examples here
so now let me define the this dual ideal
duality which is play such a role in
Reinaldo be problem so there is a
function called the trace which maps
from the ring into the ordinary rational
integers and oh the macro broke okay
this is trace of a so trace of a is just
the sum of ease and betting's so this is
going to be for the cyclotomic case here
so we take all the embeddings just sum
up the endings and then the trace of a
times B is essentially like the inner
product of the embedded a and B so this
trace product between any two elements
is basically acting like no it's not
trivial that requires proof but
fortunately that was proved in that
eighteen I don't I don't know how easy
it is to see I don't know it's not too
hard to see but it's not the trace of a
ring element is an integer
so one way you can show it is by writing
the element as a matrix fix some basis
and write it as a matrix of multiple
multiplication and then the trace of
that matrix is the is the trace of so
you can think of this trace product of
trace a a times B as the inner product
of a and B and then the dual like for
any ring or any ideal you can define a
dual of it using the ordinary definition
of duality but we'll use that we use the
trace product instead so trace of a
times D should be an integer for all A's
and so pictorially this corresponds
exactly to the dual lattice when you go
into the when you apply the embedding so
if we embed R we get this lattice here
and then the dual lattice looks exactly
like this and this is a case of a power
of two cyclotomic everything's
orthogonal and therefore the dual
lattice is also orthogonal but it's
scaled down by a factor of n R looks
like this our V looks like this it's
actually just one half of our here's
another the other example so the third
cyclotomic is now this like hexagonal
looking lattice and this is the dual
lattice here and for example these two
vectors are the dual basis of these two
so and then another interesting
interesting fact is actually RV is a
super lattice of our so every element of
our is itself an RV but in general it's
a very sparse sub lattice of RV
so these are just pictures and the
definition of RV again it just
corresponds to the dual latticed when
you when you apply this canonical
emitting
which just say that in a power of two
cyclotomic RV is just a scaling of our
as I've already mentioned and in general
you have this this kind of inclusion
here so our is a sub lattice of RV but
then also MRV is a sub R so there's
there's these are almost equal but they
have in cycle tomek's these are almost
equal but there's a slight alright so
now what I like to focus on is the
actual hardness proof for lwe or for a
ring l2v that is so the statement that
we want to prove is that under a quantum
reduction you can reduce the worst-case
SIV P approximation on ideal lattices to
decision lwe with these parameters right
so alpha here is kind of the noise rate
and the approximation will get us like
an over alpha so the reduction strategy
that will use is rather different from
the one I talked about in the previous
talk it uses the same core ingredient
the same idea of this the core
ingredient which is to go from a BDD
problem use a BDD instance and Gaussian
samples to create lwe samples but now
the way that we're going to do this we
want to go now directly to decision lwe
so the idea is to now kind of fiddle
with the error rate and detect when the
error rate decreases so if you remember
we have this we have this machine which
says
DD on L at distance D plus DG s samples
at parameter R gives you LW e samples
with basically noise D times R
Oh cute
so this is the the kind of machinery
that we have before but now one thing to
notice is that if your so if your BDD to
point is that distance D and these
samples are with parameter R then your
lwe noise is d times R so what we're
going to do is kind of essentially
fiddle with this okay gonna fiddle with
this point and try to use our elbow B
Oracle to determine whether the noise
got smaller or bigger whether the noise
parameter got smaller a bit so when the
noise parameter gets smaller that means
D actually decreased a little bit and
therefore we've gotten closer to the
less so we were at distance D we got a
little bit closer than D and then if we
can detect that by using our other
Beauty Oracle then we can continue that
process until D becomes essentially zero
so we're going to play with a alpha by
playing with our original BDD sample and
the goal is to detect when alpha has
decreased that make sense that's the
overall strategy how to implement it as
so let's suppose that we have some
Oracle which does work on lwe with
parameter alpha no noise rate alpha with
some non-negligible advantage and so
we're gonna define p of beta as the
probability that accepts when given
samples elbow buoy samples with this
kind of noise rate it so this is like an
exponential
so this might be what this might be what
it looks like right so we have some
Oracle we know that the Oracle has to
have some good advantage by assumption
at a particular error rate but at other
error rates it may have you know
terrible behavior it may actually give
the wrong answer or maybe you know gives
just flips a coin and then gives no
useful information so the the plot of
how the Oracles acceptance probability
behaves you know may look like something
crazy like this however one thing you
can notice is that when the noise gets
very large okay as the noise grows
toward infinity the Oracles acceptance
probability has to stabilize and the
reason for this is if you add a ton of
noise to lwe samples it basically just
wipes them out it just randomizes them
completely so whether you add you know a
million noise or a billion noise or a
trillion noise the distribution of the
samples is the same it's just uniform so
the as you increase the amount of noise
the Oracles acceptance probability has
to stabilize at some you know fixed
probability we'll call piece of do you
know its how much what is the Oracles
acceptance probability I'm uniformly
random samplings and another property
which we'll get to is that this graph
has to be kind of smooth as the
Lipschitz property because when you vary
the amount of noise by a tiny little bit
the probability that the Oracle probably
is acceptance that the Oracle accepts
can't change by too much
so again these are the key properties of
this P of beta it's a it's a pretty
smooth function because when you have
two different gaussians whose parameters
are very close they're statistically
these are statistically close the
probability of accepting can't change by
too much let's see okay as I already
said once beta gets big enough there's
some threshold it doesn't matter too
much what it is this P of beta is
basically P of infinity the chance that
Oh accepts on uniform sampling huge
error just and then what we also know by
assumption is that for the very specific
value of alpha that we're interested in
okay so for that specific value the
Oracle does have advantage so that means
that there's some gap between P of log
alpha and P of infinity so somewhere
between log alpha and log n basically
there's a noticeable change the
derivative of P is his nose and that's
what we're going to okay so how do
explain to Oracle as we said before with
the quantum parts I'm sorry the
classical part the core component of
ragas reduction with a BDD instance we
have dgs samples and we can produce lwe
samples with this this value
but and then the idea as I already
mentioned is to let's perturb tea a
little bit so we can run the Oracle we
can run this experiment and query the
Oracle and see how often it accepts this
case that we can perturb tea a little
bit to t-prime
do it all over again and measure how
often the Oracle accepts on this case
and basically we just want to check
whether we got closer to the latus over
here we want to check whether t-star got
appreciably closer to the lattice than
tea was and we'll do that by seeing
whether they're seeing how this this
error rate changes so one thing to
notice is that when you get closer you
end up getting a sort of a suffix of P
so now it goes from so the red port the
red part is how things would behave here
and then the green part kind of shifts
it over you said that the arrow is like
the times R so it should be like so d
this is the absolute amount of noise
that D times R and then relative to
normalized by Q that's its dr dr over Q
so the error rate is like dr over q oh
yes yeah this is a log scale plot
because the definition of p here is beta
is other being with this much
so the point is when you improve when
you manage to get closer if I've said
this right then the the plot of how
often you know the Oracle accepts is
this shift that over and you kind of see
more of you see more of the block and
the point is you can detect this ok new
Oracle and measuring it and moreover you
can you can see all this by actually
adding more error to your samples and
watching how the Oracle behaves right so
you can plot it out and notice that hey
it's it's shifted over from where it was
before that's a that I've improved I've
gotten closer so yeah that's the the
kind of core idea of course there's a
lot of technical know-how to prepare
these samples efficiently that's correct
yeah we can prepare them efficiently for
a very large radius
you know exponentially large in the
dimension which only helps us to solve
BDD to a very tiny to a very tiny
distance not terribly interesting it's
only interesting when you can iterate
and
yeah so the the quantum nature of the
iterative reduction is the same as
before
everything is so you're gonna render
miss otro direction that is improving
like how close in angles you need to get
to to the right so you need to get like
about a 1 minus 1 over N factor closer 1
minus 1 over linear n let's say closer
to detect this and and also to improve
fast enough to get to to solve the BDD
so there's a variety of ways you can
approach this one thing is to just try
all the directions parallel to the axes
and and take a step a certain step size
and one of these actually will be to
work or you can do a random perturbation
and analyze that more carefully so this
part is sort of was already known
it's detecting when you've gotten closer
by a suitable okay so actually
everything I've said here is about plain
lwe to make this work in the ring
setting we need to extend from a case
where we have a one parameter of noise
right so we have an error rate alpha
which corresponds exactly to our BDD
distance now in the ring setting there's
actually n parameters to deal with so
there's a BDD offset which is an error
vector e that is a n dimensional vector
and what comes out when you when you run
this similar or analogous procedure you
now have a noise which has n parameters
to it it's basically a scaling of this
this offset here so maybe in some court
and it's a is very tiny and in others
it's a good deal larger you get the same
kind of shape so you get a Gaussian
error rate of alpha alpha I so see it's
kind of the same picture here but these
are the n-nice parameters and now things
have to get a little bit more subtle so
we have the Oracles acceptance
probability is P of beta but this is now
mapping a vector beta to 0 beta now
encodes the end noise parameters and now
again we can say that as well actually
one one thing which is not immediate to
prove but is true is that if any single
error parameter approaches infinity then
the all the samples are completely
randomized this is actually a really key
fact so if you just you know really
crank up a single error parameter to
infinity that completely randomized the
sample so exactly what says here using
smoothing and so well
there's just one catch difficulty that
kind of doesn't generalize in the way
that we'd like it to basically the
reduction almost never produces
spherical error because there's these n
error parameters they're proportional to
the original BD the offset and those can
be arbitrary numbers so if you you know
your Oracle only works for spherical
error but your reduction can't produce
such error and the Oracle is not useful
to do so the solution is to kind of
randomize the parameters a little bit we
need a stronger assumption on the Oracle
but it doesn't just work for a spherical
error but rather it works for like
random errors with random error
parameters within a certain range now
one improvement though is that we can
get rid of an N to the fourth factor
that so let's see I think I will kind of
tend to wrap up here these are the main
ideas I'd like to close with some open
problems that would be very very very
good to solve so one thing is that we
have these worst case average case
reductions for ring lwe but they're
quantum and they're only quantum we have
no classical analog like we do with
plain overview the reason why is if you
use if you try to use the same idea that
I showed you an hour and a half ago this
reduction is completely useless in this
setting because gap SBP is actually easy
so deciding the you know deciding
between small minimum distance and large
minimum distance on ideal lattices is
trivial because the minimum distance is
always large or you can always put the
minimum distance in a very narrow range
so this reduction probably would work if
you did it but it would be completely
vacuous so we just have no ideas how to
you know D quantize this reduction in
any in any meaningful or useful that
would be great to get some foregone but
I have no idea how to do it is that
clear sometimes as mentioned in the last
slide the spherical error is is a bit of
annoying we'd like to work with
spherical error we don't want like
random error parameters when we generate
our lwv samples we did manage to prove
something about it if you limit the
number of samples the adversary gets
then you can kind of pay and end to the
fourth factor the amount of error and
then prove something about spherical
error but I would love to have it
without any degradation or with with
unbounded numbers how this certain
applications you want to give like an
unbounded number of samples to the
attacker do that with spherical error
now
let's see I guess another really
interesting question is to say we have a
reduction from ideal SIV P so that's SIV
peon ideal lattices in a fixed ring -
ring LW e for that same fixed ring but
between different rings we have almost
no relations between them we can't prove
hardly anything we can prove some
trivial stuff when one ring is a sub
ring of the other but that's about it
so completely unrelated rings how did
these problems relate to each other is
there a better choice of ring than
another we don't really know anything
about this either for for SIV P or for
ring LW e problems so I think that one
thing I'm I'd be very excited is to get
an interesting connection between two
unrelated seeming rings well so for
example you could hope to have one ring
to rule them all one ring that's
guaranteed to be as you know as hard as
all the others of the same dimension or
something like that right and then you
could say well this ring is definitely
you know a safe one to use don't really
have any idea which you know whether one
ring is weaker than another or stronger
than another we just don't know because
it rings rings rings yeah so mid the
middle product work is like maybe a step
in this direction I think right which is
it's not a ring yeah but it's something
which is ring like and and does have you
know nice connections so it is it's even
more natural you just
shinty without questioning yeah so so
there are there are steps in this
direction which have certainly been made
but right now people aren't using the
the corresponding problem right they're
not using middle product too much so if
you could actually prove stuff about you
know the problems people are using that
would be okay so it's like yes
yeah
[ __ ] interesting things okay cool and
what did they show what did they show or
work what's the nature of what they show
interest oh okay okay bye yeah I like I
mean I like metal product learning with
eras will you talk about it so I do have
some things I can say about middle
product up line but I'd love to really
have we don't know how to do that yet
but that's that we so do we know how to
build yes yeah so there's a bunch of
applications which we don't know how to
build for middle products yes we'll come
right
it's not yeah with small error with a
male organization but then you also said
and many modification is a company yeah
yeah explanation of why these two things
are not contradicting yes yeah that's a
great question and one thing that we
very frequently panicked about or
freaked out about 2010 so okay so what
this says is if these errors are small
then coordinate wise multiplication is
insecure in the like in the FFT world
like if you transfer to the frequency
domain then this is coefficient
coefficient wise multiplication but now
the errors aren't small they're there
the FFT of a small error entity yeah
okay so with F of T the answer is this
is annoyingly yet the mod Q it's
annoyingly complicated but actually it's
not the mod Q it's that they're they're
they're real numbers now so the
component wise multiplication in the in
the canonical embedding is of complex
numbers with like arbitrary precision
okay so knowing you know this thing with
a whole lot of precision is it's not an
LW it's not a one-dimensional all W
problem is Q times an integer multiple
hiding in here yeah I think okay I think
maybe it's both right it's the mod Q
which subtracts stuff from each
coordinate you know bizarre way right
after the after the multiplication
that's another weird thing that happens
so in other in other words you know what
I said here is is true
when everything's working over ZQ it
turns into a whole bunch of independent
one-dimensional lwe problem mod Q and
that you can break but when it's a when
it's in the reals or the complex numbers
and the end of shift mod Q is a weird
thing maybe this is the key to breaking
I agree I don't either
I don't either and we like you know
freaked out like many times thinking
that this is maybe some intuition to
give about the time into the one force
so they're not really yeah it's not
really distortion uh they don't have a
great explanation for this so what you'd
like to do you have a you have a
spherical noise that you'd like to kind
of get close to and you have a bounded
number of samples that three or
something like that so the point is if
you get kind of close enough to
spherical I'm not going to say this
right you help me no I don't remember
this yeah it's it's just super annoying
here it's the technical magic knowing
distribution itself is parameterize does
in every different direction yeah yeah
the noise parameters themselves are
secret yeah you sir you randomly
very public noise power meters and so is
there is some kind of any divergence
argument this that is a that is a that
is a good key point right which is the
the noise parameters are secret and
chosen at random from reveal subfield
you know there's no real subfield the
alpha this alpha is just a positive
number
yeah although each alpha comes from the
each simple logical building okay sorry
this vector alpha is an N dimensional
vector of noise widths which are applied
in each of the coordinates of the so you
have two options one is to bound the
number of samples you give out and then
we can prove something about a fixed
spherical alpha where all the alphas are
equal or if you want to give a lot of
samples out then you need these alpha is
to be round under the secret before you
even generate this M is rather I mean
it's definitely in a no technical a no
answer
yes in terms of very security
fortifications it also limits the range
of applications because exactly and no
no I don't I don't think it's that bad
right the whoever generates the Alda
beauty samples in the first place would
just choose these parameters generate
their samples and then forget you could
even throw these away it's not really a
limit to the application so much as does
your application require does your
application want like an unbounded
number of samples right is that the
security proof require a lot of
unbounded number of samples then I don't
know how to prove this without taking a
huge I think that's the main
so that's the
also who ings
that just studied yes so so it's it's
broadened out a quite a bit recently so
we can originally we chose the class of
rings was the rings of integers in
algebraic number fields now you can more
generally consider orders in orders so
some non maximal orders in and now
there's a simple proof that there's you
can get hardness for those as well it's
at their commedia like the one-step kind
of group I think that's the I think
that's the end of what's considered for
what's known as yes yes so some other
there's some works which consider even
non commutative rings which you can get
by taking an algebraic a number ring and
then doing some kind of twists to it so
there's some work on that I don't think
there's any provable hardness for that
case though so it's it's not well
understood what what happens there so
but non commutative rings are
potentially of interest
maybe those rule them all who knows yes
right so I didn't say anything about it
but by viewing ring lwe
you know these A's as matrices you can
interpolate between ring lwe and plain
lwe by taking let's say a small
dimensional matrix whose entries are
ring elements arbitrary so there's
there's no structure among those ring
elements but the elements themselves
have structure right so this is what's
known as module lwe or generalized lwe
different name
yes so you can smoothly kind of
interpolate between between the two
worlds there's a several like NIST's
submissions which this approach small
dimension over a moderate sized ring our
of two cyclotomic s-- the easiest to use
so do you think they are more likely to
be the easiest ring or that hardest ring
I mean if I had to make a bet right now
of ten dollars I would I would say that
ultimately the choice of ring has very
little effect on hardness for ring lwe
but that's just like the word like
either for worst case or for a ring all
the bv any takers yeah ten three dollars
I have like I'd say you know am I
putting ten dollars on it shows how much
conviction I have about the problem is
you can never claim you can never claim
the the BET right because you actually
have to show a separation because a
strict separation wishing one or the
other okay so in ten years what is
aboard the state of knowledge yeah kind
of artificial - right I mean so like if
I'm Damian tell me if I'm getting
anything wrong here but for a while
there was a gap in knowledge between
what we could do in cyclotomic sand then
arbitrary number fields and then that
gap closed again
yeah for like SVP on ideal it's kind of
closed or more closed right right
exactly so for a while there's a gap and
then the gap gets narrower and maybe
it'll get wider again but when is it
when is it over when it's all broken we
can then they're all equally hardened I
win the bet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]